Edwyn steers jr. where did you get the
title blood on the moon it comes from
the book of Joel in the Bible and it
wasn't the original title the original
title is six Semper Tyrannis what booth
yelled from the stage but this is really
an apocalyptic event in American history
and so I just thought that the title
which comes from the Bible where it's
apocalyptic just fit so nicely and I
think most people now agree why you
address it in your preface but why
another book on Abraham Lincoln and on
the assassination well because most of
the books that have been written on the
assassination have missed a great deal
have not really used the primary sources
to the degree that they should have been
used and in my opinion have missed some
very important aspects of the
assassination in particular dr. Mudd who
I think is featured in the book and the
connection with the Confederate Secret
Service in Canada and the military
tribunal which most historians have
treated as a legal court that lacked
jurisdiction was a kangaroo court I
don't agree with that at all I think it
had legal jurisdiction and it certainly
was not a kangaroo court and so I just
thought it was time to pull it all
together and in a book that I also tried
to make entertaining and readable the
book is shorter than most every book on
the assassination by a hundred to 150
pages and that was deliberate on my part
what's your own background and how did
you get involved in Abraham Lincoln well
my own background is science
undergraduate microbiology and my
graduate degree is in molecular biology
and I came right away University of
Pennsylvania both undergraduate and
graduate and I was hired right out of
Penn to the National Institutes of
Health in Bethesda Maryland and of
course that brought me to the epicenter
of both the Civil War and to the Lincoln
assassination and so it just slowly grew
on me in the area on weekends we would
visit the various sites and I one
weekend happened to visit the Surratt
tavern in surrattsville in Clinton
Maryland rather and that started it and
you say that's about 13 miles from where
we are yes it is yes why did that tavern
started for you what was there what you
see there
well actually I took a tour a very
famous tour that the Surratt society now
gives several times a year that's the
Surratt tavern in the lower panel as it
looks today and they give several tours
a year under the auspices of the Surratt
society which follow the escape route
beginning at Ford's Theater and going
all the way to near Bowling Green
Virginia where booth was finally
captured and shot and it is a gripping
tour it's it's a step back in history
many of the sights original sights are
there some of the properties still
remain in the same families and so it
fascinated me let's go over the basics
Abraham Lincoln was shot at what time
and where well I place at approximately
10:20 p.m. in the presidential box at
Ford's Theater where sports theater on
10th Street in Washington DC not far
from the White House which is at 16th of
course and sort of in the center of mr.
Lincoln's neighborhood who shot him John
Wilkes Booth at the time one of
America's greatest tragedians
of the famous booth family a Maryland
family from Bel Air Maryland John Wilkes
Booth by 1864 had become certainly one
of America's greatest actors and a
matinee idol extremely handsome
personable well-liked generous outgoing
seems he had everything going for him
and everybody liked him he basically had
no enemies at all how old was he he was
in his 27th year he was at the time of
the assassination he was one month short
of his 27th birthday and how did he kill
the president well he he shot him point
blank with a 41 caliber derringer
single-shot pistol probably within 2
feet of the back of his head how did he
get there well he entered a theater
which was crowded by the way a virtually
standing room he had easy full run of
the theater being a famous actor a very
close friend of the Ford family of John
Ford and his brother Harry clay Ford
that you see there so booth could come
and go in the theater basically it will
he had recognized the theater earlier in
the day made all of the arrangements
knew what he was going to do knew when
he was going to do it so he just simply
entered the theater made his way up the
staircase to the dress circle or balcony
and then slowly made his way across the
back of the theater to the box who was
sitting in the box ah Abraham Lincoln
and his wife Mary were sitting on one
side and on the other were major Henry
Rathbone and his fiancee and stepsister
Clara Harris and it was just the four of
them and when the shot was fired where
did the bullet go it entered the lower
left base of Lincoln's skull and while
there's some controversy as to the path
of the bullet I think most people agree
that it traversed
diagonally across the brain lodging
behind the right eye what happened to
the president immediately well he just
went comatose he slumped in his chair it
wasn't a violent reaction on his part
his head just fell forward Mary Lincoln
of course who was sitting right next to
him holding his hand screamed and
pandemonium broke out major Rathbone
realized what had happened jumped up and
began to grapple with booth booth had a
large bowie knife which he stabbed
Rathbone with in the arm and then
vaulted over the balustrade onto the
floor of the theater stage turned
towards the audience by most accounts
yelled Sic Semper Tyrannis thus always
to tyrants which is Virginia's was
Virginia state motto at the time is now
and then exited stage right one out the
rear door into the alley behind the
theater known as Baptist alley forts
leader had originally been a Baptist
Church tenth Street Baptist Church where
his horse was being held by a young boy
who worked for the Fords and he struck
the boy mounted the horse wheeled around
and galloped down the alley up onto at
turned left one up on the F Street
turned right and headed for the Capitol
grounds what did they do with the
president well they tried to administer
him in the Box mmm there were several
doctors in the theater the first doctor
to get to the box was Charles Leal who
was an Army sergeant and at first he
didn't know how the president was
injured or to what extent but he began
to examine him thinking that perhaps he
had a chest wound had been stabbed and
at one point ran his fingers through
Lincoln's hair and noticed blood on his
hand and then of course he found the
entry wound
and a blood clot had already formed
which essentially suppress Lincoln's
breathing and Lille removed the blood
clot and Lincoln began to breathe quite
normally and his pulse restored at that
point several other doctors came into
the box they consulted and pretty much
agreed that they had to move Lincoln in
the interim by the way who was the
actress that held the president's head
Laura keen she was starring in the play
it was a benefit performance for Laura
keen that evening that is all of the
proceeds from that evening would go to
Laura keen as a rewarder and ppreciate
for her role as a star and she she was
starring in the play that evening our
American cousin which is a British spoof
on American bumpkins a play that Lincoln
would really enjoy very much she made
her way to the box and that's
interesting how she was able to make her
way to the box but she did and asked
Lille if she could rest Lincoln's head
in her lap and he said yes and so she
did by the way go back to them this is
10 something at night on April 14
correct
when did grant meet Lee at Appomattox on
the 9th April 9th so this is five days
later Lee has surrendered the Army of
Northern Virginia Washington is
celebrating wildly every day there are
illuminations throughout the city which
hard for us to understand today but
they're rather spectacular where
everything is illuminated with all forms
of light and and so Lincoln and Mary
Lincoln were having a night out of
relaxation enjoyment and basically
celebrating what would effectively be
viewed as the end of the war but this is
an important point particularly from
booths perspective of course it wasn't
the end of the
there was still a hundred and
seventy-five thousand Confederate troops
in the field about eighty five thousand
in North Carolina under Joe Johnston
about fifty five thousand in the
trans-mississippi area under Kirby Smith
Confederate General Kirby Smith and then
about 35,000 scattered in various places
throughout the south that's a
substantial number of Confederate troops
now while it's impractical the idea is
if there was some way to join up those
troops you would have a formidable force
that could face Sherman and grant and
perhaps continue the hopes of the
Confederacy how long did they keep
President Lincoln in the theater a
matter of minutes um in the sense that
they probably moved him over to the
Petersen house directly across the
street certainly between quarter of 11
and 10 minutes to 11 probably you paint
the picture of him being carried out of
the theater with no place to go yes when
they when they lifted him and started to
carry him out of the theater they
weren't quite sure where obviously they
knew they would take him to a building
or a home somewhere on the street and as
they emerged from the front of the
theater onto the sidewalk they were
beckoned by a young soldier across the
street who told them to bring Lincoln
into this particular house it was the
home of a tailor by the name of Peterson
rather substantial home three floors
several rooms and they took him into a
back bedroom on the on what was the
second floor you have to walk up the
steps you have a picture in the book
which is after the fact after the
president dies the next morning how did
they get this picture a remarkable
picture it's one of the most haunting
pictures to me I think this picture is
obviously taken very shortly after
Lincoln's body was removed and taken
back to the White House and everyone had
left the Peterson house there were two
brother photographers that boarded at
the Peterson house Julius and Henry
alkie
later became very well-known
photographers in Washington and they
brought down their wet plate camera set
it up and shot that photograph and I
think what's interesting to me in that
photograph is you'll notice that all the
bed clothing is still on the bed and
that coverlet that you see in the
picture on the bed shows up later and a
few exhibitions but then disappears and
we don't know what happened to it or
where it is today hopefully it's in some
Lincoln collection private Lincoln
collection somewhere but Lincoln when he
was brought to the Peterson house and
put in that bed was stripped he was
naked and then once he got there once he
got there they removed all of his
clothes and examined his body completely
and then began to do everything that
they of course agreed that the wound was
mortal and there was nothing they could
do except make him comfortable and
that's what they tried to do and it and
and they they brought hot water bottles
of mustard plasters tried to warm his
body because the extremities were very
cold you say there's no room in that
little room and that also how many
people visited before he died well I I
personally have calculated 57 people
visited the room I've since uh come to
the conclusion that there was a 58 so
during the night and he's there for nine
hours from by quarter eleven to seven 22
when he died
fifty-eight people visited house now of
course not all at once there's toy they
could fit in that room which several
edgings and drawings have shown
basically fifty-eight people standing in
the room around the bed hence it's been
dubbed the rubber room I think that at
the moment of his death death I
calculate there were perhaps twelve
people around the bed when he died one
thing I wanted to point out about the
bed dressing and the coverlet is that
Lincoln is naked of course and yet all
of the bed clothing is still there so
when they removed his body it it
occurred to me that they obviously
wouldn't
move a man like Abraham Lincoln naked
and and that's where I first found
reports that they had sent for a very
plain wooden pine box and wrapped his
body in an American flag and placed the
wrapped body in the box and then took it
back to the White House which is I think
a rather interesting touch and of course
what happened to the flag it's obviously
a would become an American icon you do
have a flag on the back cover of your
book you say we didn't discover until
1998 correct where did you find this
well I didn't find it of course but it
was found in the Hartford Historical
Society in Hartford Connecticut what
flag is this this is the flag that I
believe as you look at the box was was
mounted on a staff on the left-hand side
of the box I think the people at the
Hartford Historical Society feel it was
on the right hand side but I feel it was
on the left but nonetheless it was one
of the five flags that decorated the box
now one of those flags of course is
famous well-known and it is on display
at Ford's Theatre but the other four
flags have disappeared into history and
so one of the little side lights is
trying to track down those flags what
happened to them where are they now and
miraculously this flag is found in a
storage room at the Hartford Historical
Society in a box all folded up where it
had been
I guess residing since probably the
1930s was probably the last time it went
out on display it was in terrible
condition it's a silk flag and of course
they are extremely fragile
they had it beautifully restored and
it's now on display at the Hartford
hystory it's a magnificent item go back
to your original comments about primary
sources first of all how many different
books have been written about Abraham
Lincoln well or how much is just the
general question how much
and that's an important point and it
also is an important point in studying
his assassination judge Frank Williams
who you have had on c-span many
occasions as a Lincoln scholar is
currently compiling a bibliography in
conjunction with Brown University and
judge Williams tells me that there are
now over 16,000 bibliographic entries
under Lincoln and they're growing weekly
of the 16,000 I have counted 3400
approximately 3,400 or 20% devoted to
his assassination and of the 3400 there
are presently 104 books monographs
devoted exclusively to the assassination
now one of the problems while Lincoln
certainly is one of the most widely
written about individuals in all of
Western literature some say second only
to Jesus Christ of the hundred and four
books hundred plus authors only two are
professionally trained historians or
academic historians and only four of the
books have been published by university
presses or academic presses and the
significance of that is that the usual
standard of peer review which is
practiced by university presses and
academic process I think is basically
lacking in this great body of literature
on Abraham Lincoln that's been published
and and so it's a story that is filled
with a great deal of myths and erroneous
information and unfortunately many of
the myths or manufactured myths give us
them well one of the most prominent is
that Edwin Stanton Lincoln's Secretary
of War was somehow behind Lincoln's
assassination that he engineered it
together with Radical Republicans to
eliminate Lincoln now that the war was
over essentially in one so that the
Radical Republicans could basically have
their way with the south
that's another myth um well the one that
I like the best of course is that Mary
Surratt and Samuel Mudd are innocent
victims who was Mary Surratt Mary
Surratt was the woman who owned the
tavern Surratt Tavern in surrattsville
and the boardinghouse in Washington not
many blocks from Ford's Theatre which
became a center for the conspirators to
meet and including John Wilkes Booth and
several of the conspirators actually
boarded for a brief period of Mary
Surratt sport you say that boarding
house is still there it is it its
original dress was 541 H Street its
current address is now the numbers were
changed in the 1870s I believe and it's
now an even number in the 600's I forgot
the numbers around 620 H Street it's
it's a Chinese restaurant name of golos
Gio - ello the picture in my book was
taken just before it became a restaurant
when it was a grocery store not to get
too far our head in the story but you
mentioned Mary Surratt and this picture
she's in there somewhere she is on the
extreme left of the four bodies that are
hanging she was one of the four that
were condemned to death by hanging and
became in some ways that cause celeb not
nearly as much as dr. Mudd has become a
cause so first woman ever be hanging
America correct by a the federal
government of course there were many
women that had been hanged but the first
by the federal government and you
mentioned dr. Samuel Mudd what's the
myth about him well that dr. Samuel Mudd
was nothing more than a simple country
doctor who was persecuted for nothing
more than administering the Hippocratic
oath to an injured man who was seeking
medical attention and that injured man
was John Wilkes Booth booth and Herold
arrived at dr. Mudds house four and a
half hours after the assassination this
him right that's dr. Mudd on the left
and an important figure on the right
Thomas Harbin who most people have not
heard of but dr. mudd arranged an
important meeting between John Wilkes
Booth and Thomas Harbin at the building
and the lower picture of the page the
Bryan Town Tavern in Bryan Town Maryland
very close to where dr. Mudd lives
dr. Mudd by the way in this picture up
here is how old he's 32 in that picture
yes now he is often referred to in the
in most of the books as 40 42 the
newspapers of the day characterized him
in his 40s but he's 32 years old he's
born in 1833 on the farm
which his father owned 1,700 acres in
Charles County Maryland Maryland just
north of Bryan town which still exists
today is a small little village of a few
houses and spent his whole life on the
mud farm near Bryan Town Maryland go
back to we have Abraham Lincoln dying at
7:22 on April the 15th John Wilkes Booth
left the theater the night before where
does he go he heads over the Navy Yard
bridge over the Anacostia or Eastern
branch of the Potomac and directly into
Southern Maryland and goes straight to
the Surratt tavern which is
approximately 13 miles southeast of
Washington where he picks up a carbine
and a pair of binoculars and some
whiskey and then heads on directly to
dr. Mudds house okay as he arrives at
4:00 a.m. before we do that go back to
the assassination of Abraham Lincoln how
many other people were involved in and
around that story at that moment in the
town of Washington well what else was
going on and what since the conspiracy
well there were ten conspirators
that were eventually charged with
Lincoln's murder but there were
certainly many more people that had
knowledge of the conspiracy and
participated in the conspiracy mostly
after the fact although there were a few
Thomas Harbin being one who was brought
into the conspiracy beforehand by dr.
Mudd but there were by my count
probably 26 people who could have been
charged under Stanton's Edict of aiding
and abetting booth both before and after
what was Stanton's job he was Secretary
of War and of course a very powerful man
what was his relationship with Abraham
Lincoln very close again it's it's
another one of the myths that have come
out of the Civil War in this episode
that Stanton and Lincoln were somehow
estranged
where was Stanton that night he was home
he was preparing to go to bed when word
came by a pound on the door and a
messenger that said that Seward
Secretary of State William Seward had
been killed at his home and the
President had been shot there was a
little bit of confusion because Stanton
said thought that Seward and Lincoln had
been attacked together and of course
Seward was bedridden he was recuperating
from a very serious carriage accident he
was bedridden but a Stanton soon
realized that there were two separate
incidents and so he went downstairs got
a carriage and went to Seward's house
where he met Gideon Welles the Secretary
of the Navy arriving at the same instant
and they went upstairs and checked on
Seward and while it was a horrific sight
there was blood everywhere Seward was
alright his wounds were superficial what
had happened to him he had been attacked
by one of the conspirators by Lewis
Powell man in the lower right picture
there with wearing the Hat a key figure
one of the four to behind how old 21 at
the
I'm a very tall athletic individual had
served with Mosby was brought into the
conspiracy we believe by John Surratt
the son of Mary Surratt the son of Mary
Surratt another key figure and the
individual introduced to booth by dr.
Mudd another reason that I feel that dr.
Mudd is not just a co-conspirator but a
key conspirator because he brought two
very important people into the
conspiracy John Surratt and Thomas
Harbin take a little bit of time and
talk about the Seward attempted
assassination and how did this young man
get get into the house and get up to
where he was in bed well actually it was
it was very skillful and this belies one
of the common beliefs that Lewis Powell
was of somewhat low mental capability
somewhat of a stooge of John Wilkes
Booth and yet he shows a great deal of
intelligence and how he handled himself
he goes to Seward's house with a bottle
of medicine and when he's met at the
door by one of Seward's servants he says
that Seward's doctor Tullio Verity who
was Seward's doctor so Pound knew this
had sent this medicine over and he was
to deliver it to secretary Seward
personally he basically forced his way
into the hallway of the home and started
to go up the steps when Seward's son
Augustus Seward met him and challenged
him and Powell still maintained that he
was under orders to deliver the medicine
only to Seward and so Seward's son would
not allow him up further up the
staircase pal turned as if he was going
to go down the staircase but then
wheeled around pulled out his revolver
and fired point-blank at Augustus Seward
the gun misfired and so he bludgeoned
him over the head with it very seriously
fractured his skull and made his way to
the Seward bedroom where he dove on top
of Seward literally with a bowie knife
and just began flailing and stabbing
away at Seward and then he was
interrupted by a male nurse George
Robinson who had come into the room
hearing the shouts and the screaming and
they fought and he stabbed Robinson and
this is going on what at what time this
is going on at the same time
approximately a Booth is shooting
Lincoln approximately at 10:30 so it's
coordinated and that's an important how
badly was Seward wounded well his wounds
were disfiguring he was stabbed in the
face and it was a very serious cut that
ran from ear to jaw which disfigured him
for life but it wasn't in any way
life-threatening to him he actually
fought back even though he had a broken
jaw and that's what he was recuperating
from in bed and struggled with Powell
until help came in the way of George
Robinson and Powell then fled he he
turned ran out of the room down the
stairs out the front door presumably
screaming I'm mad I'm mad and David
Herold
was supposed to be tending his horse
outside Harold who is one of the
conspirators in the plot and one of the
four to be hanged
had accompany pal to Seward's house this
is David's David Herold there again he
young 21-year old but when Harold heard
the sounds coming out of the Seward
house and the screaming he apparently
panicked we don't know that for sure but
that's a suspicion and he turned and
rode away leaving Pals horse there but
abandoning pal what did pal do
mounted his horse and headed out of the
city or tried to now we think that
Harold a company pal because he didn't
know his way around Washington and
presumably Harold would lead pal
out of the city to rendezvous with booth
but being abandoned Powell rode off into
the city and all we know is that his
horse was found in the vicinity of a
congressional cemetery by the way all
these conspirators you say there's
something like 26 and how many
participated that night that night four
participated booth at Sarat Harold and
Powell now we haven't talked about at
Sarat but he was the man he's in the
upper right who was assigned to
assassinate Andrew Johnson the Vice
President Andrew Johnson is currently
living at the Kirkwood Hotel which is at
12th and Pennsylvania short distance
away from Ford's Theater at Surratt had
taken a room early that morning in the
Kirkwood hotel and at approximately
10:30 was to go to the hotel knock on
the door and assassinate Andrew Johnson
he did go to there to the Kirkwood house
in order to drink at the bar he was
within feet of Johnson's room but as I
say apparently his courage evaporated
and he turned and fled mounted his horse
wrote about the city saw the commotion
and heard the commotion on 10th Street
realized that Booth had carried out the
assassination of Lincoln and that's rot
returned his horse to a stable and
boarded a trolley and went down to the
Navy Yard tried to stay there stay with
a friend but the friend refused to have
him so Harold came back into the city on
the trolley and checked in to that's
around 8:00 I'm sorry I swatted and
checked into the Pennsylvania House or
Kimmel House hotel and spent the night
there by the way this is going on where
is Mary Surratt Mary Surratt is inter
boardinghouse on H Street on H Street
and interestingly enough she's visited
by two o'clock that morning um what is
she all about by the way well she is a
widow she was widowed in 1862 when her
husband died left her with considerable
debts but also with property the Surratt
tavern surrounding land and the boarding
house in Washington she had three
children
John Isaac and he younger daughter Anna
Isaac was away serving in the
Confederate Army John had come back home
when his father died to help his mother
and he John actually became postmaster
surrattsville he was then discharged for
disloyalty after it was found out that
he was a Confederate agent or suspected
of being a canoe ask you about this
Washington DC was north or south at the
time well it was within the Union lines
but Washington DC was thoroughly a
southern city filled with Confederate
sympathizers during the war during the
war you have to remember that most of
all the able-bodied men are gone
into the Union Army or fled south and
joined the Confederate Army Virginia
belonged to the south could people come
and go from Virginia across the Potomac
into the district they could bypass
access into Washington was over a series
of bridges Long Bridge the Navy Yard
bridge the Benning Road bridge all of
these bridges were guarded by troops by
Union troops and passage in and out of
the city was bypassed
only however it was not all that
difficult to pass it in out of the city
and it seems to me that most of the
attention was paid at night and to
people coming into the city not leaving
because the threat posed to the city of
Washington as people coming in not
people going out now what about Maryland
Maryland is in the Union in essence by
force the Maryland legislature was
prevented from holding a convention or
meeting to vote on secession it is a
clear they would have but they were
arrested held temporarily until a crisis
passed then released and Marilyn
remained in the Union obviously because
Washington DC sits in Maryland and you
can't have the capital of the Union
surrounded by Confederate territory
Maryland is viewed as a in many ways as
a Confederate state certainly
sympathizing with the Confederate all of
southern maryland the six counties of
southern maryland whereas Confederate is
Richmond but Maryland sent twice as many
men into the Union Army as it sent into
the Confederate Army but those were
mostly
northern and western Maryland
so that the night of the assassination
you had four people involved directly
yes you named him earlier John Wilkes
Booth David Herold George Andrew
Atzerodt
and Louis Powell Powell who is standing
by outside of that group and where are
they well the other there are six other
conspirators that are tried of samuel
arnold michael o'laughlen Mary Surratt
Edmond Spangler dr. Mudd and who have I
missed John Surratt John Surratt is on
his way to Canada and he's in Elmira New
York at the moment that the
assassination takes place I know why is
he in this outfit well because he did
make his way to Canada and he was hidden
by Jesuit priests in Canada who
eventually helped him make his way to
England and from England he made his way
to the Vatican and he became a papal
suave part of the papal guards in the
Vatican
and ironically an old schoolmate of his
was also a papal swab who recognized him
as John Surratt he had used the alias
Watson John Watson and of course knowing
that there was a reward for the capture
of John Surratt of 25,000 dollars he
turned John Surratt in Surratt was taken
in custody by the papal authorities but
he he escaped and a Hollywood type
escape where he literally jumped over a
high precipice made his way to the
coastline and boarded a freighter for
Alexandria Egypt where he was arrested
in February of 1867 in Alexandria and
brought back to the United States and
put on trial in June of 1867 so about
what is it two years after all the yes
motion Mary Surratt stood at her
boarding house he's on his way to Canada
whereas dr. Mudd he's at his home in
near Beantown in Charles County roughly
how far from where we're sitting about
30 miles who is samuel arnold samuel
arnold is one of the conspirators of
baltimore ian samuel arnold and michael
o'laughlen the man next to him the
photograph next to him were two
Baltimoreans who were both a childhood
friends of John Wilkes Booth samuel
arnold attended st. Timothy's hall which
still exists in Catonsville Maryland as
students and Michael Laughlin lived
across the street from John Wilkes Booth
in Baltimore the booths owned a home on
Exeter Street in addition to their home
in Bel Air Maryland what did these two
people have to do with all of us well
they were the very first men that John
Wilkes Booth recruited into his
conspiracy he met with them in August of
1864 in Baltimore at the Barnum Hotel
and he proposed
this plot to capture Abraham Lincoln and
take him south to Richmond
what was the motive for John Wilkes
Booth for the capture plot the motive of
course was to presumably exchange
Lincoln use them as a bargaining chip
during the Civil War they had a process
known as exchange where prisoners were
exchanged rank for rank so you could
exchange a private for a private a
general for a general and that was
carried out throughout the war when
grant became a general and chief of the
armies in March of 1864 he suspended
prisoner exchange because the South was
losing its manpower and the North could
keep replenishing its manpower grant
realized that it was in fact aiding the
Confederacy to allow these Confederate
prisoners to be exchanged and go back
into the army so he suspended it so one
of the motives presumably that Booth had
was to capture Lincoln and take him to
Richmond the question is how many
soldiers is a President of the United
States worth a division no one really
knows
as you know in March they tried to they
had a plot to kidnap the president tell
us that story
and what happened about well the
original plots there were six plots that
were directed against Abraham Lincoln
beginning in 1861 and ending with the
final assassination plot in April but
booth had actually entered into a plot
to capture Lincoln on March the 17th of
1865 he had found out after visiting
Ford's Theater earlier in the day that
Lincoln was to attend a special
performance of players at Campbell
Hospital which is was on the northern
boundary of Washington in those days
it's were Florida Avenue exists now in
North East Washington Lincoln was to
attend the performance so booth quickly
gathered together his conspirators and
they went out to the vicinity of
Campbell Hospital a booth
had the rest of his conspirators stay at
a restaurant nearby while he went
actually a cable Hospital where he
learned that Lincoln did not come to the
performance he canceled his appearance
and what I am doing he stayed in
Washington at the National Hotel - with
the governor of Indiana - except the
captured Confederate flag from an
Indiana regiment 140th Indiana and so
Lincoln felt it was more important to
meet the soldiers of 140th Indiana and
accept the captured Confederate battle
flag interestingly enough it happened at
Booth's Hotel where he had a room and
was staying go back again to the night
of the assassination of Abraham Lincoln
they got Seward chopped him up pretty
good he lived did not get Andrew Johnson
was there anybody else here trying to
get why didn't they go after Stanton
well there is some who feel that Stanton
was early on a target as was General
Grant it certainly there it appears as
if Stanton's house was cased in that an
individual showed up there two days
before this came out in the trial later
but we know nothing more than that and
it may or may not have actually happened
and the house may have been cased and
grant certainly appears to have been a
target but grant left earlier in the
afternoon so he wasn't at Ford's Theater
did Jefferson Davis know about this well
that's the great controversy now there
is no evidence or direct evidence or
even smoking gun that you can place this
on the desk of Jefferson Davis but
certainly the Confederate Secret Service
knew about it and was involved in
helping booth assemble his conspiracy
and helped him afterwards to escape and
so there are those who say and I happen
to believe this myself that those
agents would have never acted on their
own and involved themself with John
Wilkes Booth they weren't rogue agents
and they this information they would
have reported up to their superiors
their superiors clearly would have
reported this up to Richmond but you
report that the Union folks did the same
thing to the south it worked both ways
the Civil War
characterized by Winston Churchill as
the last war fought by gentlemen
deteriorated significantly by 1864 we
see the beginnings of black flag warfare
and I devote a chapter to that where
acts begin to take place that are
outside the Articles of War and outside
the recognized rules of warfare
basically targeting civilians civilian
populations as well as civilian
individuals but clearly there was an
attempt known as the Dahlgren raid to
sack Richmond and according to papers
found on the officers body to find
Jefferson Davis and his cabinet and
killed them and they just you were
saying that I was thinking about the
other and there's so much similarity of
what's going on in the world today is
why I want to bring this one up and it's
offbeat though but it's the story of the
yellow fever and North Carolina the
yellow fever plot one of the Confederate
agents dr. Luke Blackburn a very
prominent physician from Kentucky helped
the Confederacy early on as a blockade
runner but made his way to Canada in
1864 at the very time that Jefferson
Davis had set up Confederate Secret
Service in Canada and he developed a
plot to introduce yellow fever into the
north in several areas Washington being
one of the area's New Bern North
Carolina being
the areas I knew blur it wasn't Newbern
a part of the south no it was in Union
hands and it was a base staging base
there were a lot of Union troops around
there and what Blackburn did was a
terrible yellow fever epidemic broke out
in Bermuda in the spring of 1864 he was
an authority on yellow fever recognized
internationally as authority on yellow
fever he offered his services to the
Bermuda government and they readily
accepted but his motives were alterior
he went there and with the idea of
collecting infected clothing both
bedding and personal clothing from
individuals that died of yellow fever
and then having that clothing
distributed amongst certain populations
in certain cities with the idea of
inducing or starting a yellow fever
epidemic now we know today that yellow
fever is not contagious it's it's
carried by a virus transmitted through a
mosquito but it's not transmitted
between human beings but they didn't
know that they thought it was contagious
and in fact at the very time that this
clothing was distributed Newburn a
yellow fever epidemic broke out in which
2,000 civilians in Newbern died but they
didn't cause it they didn't cause it
they thought they did but they didn't
cause it and Blackburn was eventually
taken into custody in Canada and put on
trial in Canada for violation of the
neutrality act and the the New Bern
incident was introduced into that trial
along with with is introducing clothing
into Washington DC now he had also
attempted to do this with Abraham
Lincoln he had bought several very fine
sharks dress shirts which he had had
packed with yellow fever contaminated
clothing so he thought and then put the
shirts in a very nice expensive Veliz
and gave it to one of his agents to
deliver to the White House to Abraham
Lincoln as a gift in all of these acts
the thing that you have to realize while
you may target an individual there
discriminant and so if this was a
contagion if it had been smallpox for
instance very likely Abraham Lincoln
would have contracted smallpox as would
his wife and children and other people
in the White House now when we started
and she said that you went to primary
sources and you talked about in the
preface three different individuals that
were involved in the transcripts from
the Commission's the trial three
different ones but they were different
three different publications yes of the
transcript yes they were different the
the first one to come out was by
Peterson TB Peterson in Philadelphia let
me back up each day first of all all of
the testimony was taken down in
shorthand a form of shorthand known as
phonography and then it was translated
that evening copies were made by a very
interesting process and those copies
that were made were distributed to the
defense counsel to the prosecution
counsel into the newspapers the daily
transcripts were communicated to
Philadelphia by Morse code and appeared
in the Philadelphia Enquirer the next
day verbatim as they were in the
Washington Intelligencer in Washington
appeared the next day for Batum so
people could read the previous day's
trial proceedings Peterson took the
philadelphia inquirer transcripts from
the daily papers and published them in a
book unedited uncorrect 'add filled with
typographical errors because it's being
transmitted by Morse code and so there's
a lot of error in the transmission that
was the earliest edition to come out in
1865 that was followed by a second
publication by Ben pearly poor who was a
newspaper man who published a
three-volume set of the transcripts
edited that is corrected for error
typographical error and the third
publication that came out later in
November of a
1865 was by Ben Pittman and he was the
man who received the government contract
to actually record the daily proceedings
of the trial how many of those have you
read all of them how long are they well
uh both the Pittman is condensed what
Pittman did was uh he eliminated the
questions and only publishes the answers
and in some instances he summarizes the
answers but he tried very hard to be
very accurate and in most instances he
was it is the common book today the
common transcript today that people can
find because it was reprinted in 1954 in
1990 how much do you rely on that for
your book
well I rely on the original transcript
I've used the Pittman because Pittman
also indexed and he gathered all of the
testimony together pertaining to a
single subject which is very valuable so
you can look up an individual defendant
or you can look up a witness in his
indexing and go to that testimony even
though it may be summarized and
condensed but it serves as a guide to go
to the full transcript and pour the
three volumes set but you have to
understand that the trial didn't follow
a sequence so sometimes witnesses were
called out of sequence how many
witnesses were there I count 366 how
many days with the trial fifty and this
was one of these tribunals like we hear
talk to military tribunal uh and we're
seeing very much the same thing today
Andrew Johnson by executive order
established the military tribunal and
placed the defendants under the
jurisdiction of the military tribunal he
said there are 5,000 of those drains
them or there are approximately 5,000
military tribunals uh somewhere between
fourteen thousand and fifteen thousand
individuals were tried by military
tribunal as you know we haven't gotten
to one twentieth it's in this book and I
want to make sure we talk a little bit
about your background what are you doing
now full-time writing how many books
have you written uh five three paperback
and
to hard cover the one immediately
preceding this was on exclusively on dr.
mudd and what do you live in Berkeley
Springs West Virginia which is about a
hundred miles due west of here how long
do you spend with NIH 31 years when did
you retire 1994 wonderful and are you
going to do more books on Abraham
Lincoln yes I'm now doing a special
edited annotated version of Pittman the
University Press of Kentucky has
approved doing that and they did this
book they dressed if they did this book
I when you look back at the your book on
on Samuel Mudd and you also have a
chapter to and hearing you talk about
him how big a controversy is that's
continued to be I mean the mud family
continues to try to get him yes
exonerated very big controversy in many
ways it's a very interesting story
because it it it shows what can happen
in history when people attempt to
manufacture history and revise it
the mud myth is a manufactured myth by
the mud family beginning with his
daughter Nettie Mudd Monroe when she
published a book in 1906 called the life
of dr. Samuel a mud and currently his
grandson dr. Richard Mudd who is a
hundred and one will be a hundred and
two I believe On January 12th of 2002
has devoted 70 plus years to exonerating
his grandfather and what is your
number-one proof that Samuel Mudd was a
conspirator and was deeply involved in
almost well primarily the meetings with
John Wilkes Booth which were all
arranged there were three of them that
we know of there may have been more but
we can document three of them but most
importantly when booth first began to
put his conspiracy together
they're meeting with Arnall and
O'Laughlin the very next thing he did
was go to Canada and he met in Montreal
with a Confederate Secret Service agent
who headed the office in Montreal and he
stayed for ten days and when he left he
carried a letter of introduction from
that Confederate agent to dr. Mudd and a
man named dr. William Queen both lived
in Charles County Maryland and if you
think about that it ties booth and dr.
Mudd into the Confederate Secret Service
directly and it means that Patrick
Martin in Montreal knew dr. Mudd and
knew that he was the man John Wilkes
Booth needed to see we only have a
minute and this is unfair but on John
Wilkes Booth the controversy about him
being in that barn when it was burned
and when he was shot is there any doubt
in your mind that that was anybody but
John Mills none whatsoever
another manufactured myth and it's I
think rather easy to disprove but it
requires really going to the
documentation it was the guy that showed
up years later and said he was John
Wilkes Booth a man by the name of David
David George David II George who showed
up in 1903 and claimed that he was John
Wilkes Booth you say that we only have
30 seconds that John Wilkes Booth they
tried to exhume him a couple years ago
and that wasn't the first time he they
didn't get it done this time how many
times has he been exhumed uh I think
three times but the first two were
natural is when he was turned over to
the family we are out of time we have to
quit this Edward steers jr. here's the
cover your book blood on the moon the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln thank
you very much thank you for reviving